Well, it's an unsettled picture as we head towards the end of the week.
This afternoon it'll be cold, wet and windy across most of Scotland.
We're under the influence of low pressure...
...and this weather front pushing northwest is bringing cloud and outbreaks of rain.
The rain, of course, will be heaviest over the borders and around Edinburgh,...
...where it could lead to difficult conditions on the roads.
In the west, rain will be lighter and patchier.
There would, maybe a few drier interludes over Dumfries House in Ayrshire.
There will be snow for the higher ground of the highlands and Aberdeenshire.
The potential for a few flurries over Balmoral...
Who the hell wrote this script?
...as the afternoon goes on.
The best of the drier and brighter weather will, of course, be over the northern isles and the far north of the mainland.
So, a little hazy sunshine for the Castle of Mey and Caithness,...
...but a cold day everywhere with temperatures of just eight Celsius and a brisk, northeasterly wind.
Thank God it isn't a bank holiday!